في استراليا المفتوحه للتنس الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه لاعب اساسي هو جواد العلي يفتح
نقاش على المنصات عن قدمي هو ماسك يهاجم
دافوس مملورايح والمؤتمر يرد ما عزمناك
اصلا اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
بطوله استراليا المفتوحه هي واحده من اهم
اربع بطولات في التنس المعروفين
جالس بيصير جدل حوالينا بيخلي الاهتمام
فيها يتضاعفوا يتجاوز متابعي ومحبي التنس
حول العالم البطوله انطلقت من يومين ومن
وقتها شايفينها ساحه منى
لكن للاسف موسيقى رياضي او تنافس في
اللعبه الروسيه الاوكرانيه مسجل نفسها
حاضره بقوه في البطوله ومشاركه اكثر من
لاعب اساسي يعني كانها القصه بدات طبعا
لما سفير اوكرانيا في استراليا نشر صوره
بتظهر العالم الروسي في مدرجات المشجعين
واذان واستنكر رفع العلم الروسي طالب
الاتحاد الاسترالي بتطبيق قاعده العلم
المحايد فورا العالم كان موجود في مباراه
اللاعبه الاوكرانيه كاترينا بدال امام
اللاعبه الروسيه كامله رهيبه وبالمناسبه
مشاهدينا بطوله استراليا المفتوحه مثل
الموضوع البطولات والرياضات مؤخرا سامحه
للاعبي روسيا وبيلا روسيا انه بيلعبوا
ولكن تحت علم محايد بدون تمثيل وطني او
تمثيل لبلادهم او حتى وحتى في المباريات
جنب اسمهم بينحط علم ابيض على عكس باجيب
اللاعبين اللي بينحط جنب اسمائهم اعلام
بلادهم يعني بعد الاحتجاج الاوكراني هذا
الاتحاد الاسترالي الاستجابه وطلع بيان
قال فيه صحيح كنا سامحين بحمل الاعلام
الروسيه والروسيه لكن اذا ما سبب
استخدامها ازعاج ولكننا الان مضطرين اننا
نمنعناعها السفاره الروسيه ردت على القرار
وصفته بالمؤسف والتلاعب السياسي وقالت مو
كفايه اللي صاير في لاعبين واجبارهم على
اللعب على المحايد لا كمان تبغوا حتى
الجمهور ما يعرف يشجعهم هذه مو هي الواقعه
الوحيده اللي حرب روسيا واو سجلت فيها
حضوره في استراليا المفتوحه السنه ففي
لاعبه اوكرانيه اسمها مارتو كوستوك وهي
المصنفه الخامسه عالميا رفضت مصافحه خصمها
في المباراه فيكتوريا ازارينكا لانها من
بيلاروسيا وجاءت انها ما راح تصافح اي
لاعب روسيه او بالروسيه الا لو كانوا من
اللي اذان الحرب بوضوح وكان سبق ولها نفس
الموقف في بطوله امريكا المفتوحه في 20 22
ووقتها تصدرت العناوين على العموم هذه مو
اول مره بنشوف الحرب الروسيه الاخرانيه
داخله في الرياضه السنه الماضيه تحديدا في
التنس ايضا بطوله الشهيره رفضت للرسول
الروسيين تماما انهم يشاركوا في البطوله
ورابطه التنس العالم يحتجته حرمه البطوله
من احتساب نقاطها في التصنيف العالمي
وشوفنا فيك كاس العالم لكره القدم كيف
استبعدت روسيا ودخلت مكانها بولندا كثير
ناس شايفه اللي بيصير اسلوب ضغط على روسيا
وبلاسيا يعني وانه مش دي مفيد لكن كمان في
كثير ناس معترضين وشايفين الموضوع جالس
يخرب رياضه وان السياسه المفروض تكون
بعيده خلونا نتكلم في هذا الموضوع اكثر مع
ضيفنا اللي بينضم الينا المحلل الرياضي
حسن دراز اهلا فيك معانا حسن خليني في
البدايه اسالك بما انه في اصلا انقسام في
هذا الموضوع خليني اعرف منك انت بتميل لي
اي جهه او وجهه نظر
اهلا بك
همم
الرياضه
وملعب كره القدم
الموضوع بياثر بشكل كبير يعني ماشي بس على
على الرياضتين لكن حتى عنده درجات دلوقت
مثلا مشجع بلد معين وانت دلوقت عايزني لا
ارفع الاعلام اللي عايز تقلق بشكل كويس
يعني اي شيء عايز يتصرف بشكل معين فالامور
بقت الدخله في الرياضه بشكل كبير جدا بس
حتى الناس لكن حتى في كره القدم دلوقت
ممنوع ان قاعدين في الدوري الروسي او في
دوري الابطال الروسي دلوقت ان هم يلعبوا
ان هم ينتقلوا بالفلوس الى الدوارات
الاخرى في الجروب او في العالم كله
اللعيبه اللي موجوده دي ممكن انها كمان
تقدر
الامور بقت مؤثره بشكل كبير جدا وفي مساله
الرياضه
من الاساس يعني مثلا لو مسكنا حادثه انه
اللاعب رفضت تسلم على اللاعبه الاخرى
دائما في موضوع التنس يعني خصوصا تتناس
تحديدا كرياضه دائما الكلام فيها عن
الاخلاق والاخلاقيات اللعب وهكذا وهذا
الموضوع طبعا كله في الرياضه بشكل عام
يعني بس انه في التنس بشكل اكبر هل هذا
يعتبر خرق للقواعد ولا لا انه من حقها او
لانه اوكرانيه بيمرروا لها
او اهم
تحدي
انت دلوقت لو انا
يعني في امر سياسيه بيننا علاقه لازم يكون
في سلام لان هو ده الهدف من الرياضه
ههه
بيكون فيه رساله مميزه
هل سببه شفنا هذا الموقف الان اللي بيصير
مع روسيا وبالروسيا هل سبق وشوفنا صار قبل
كده في الرياضه ضد اي دوله بسبب اي اي سبب
اخر ايضا سياسي
لكن اعتقد في كره القدم
25 25
حاليا في كلام كل ده الكبيره زي دي
المواصفات العملاق اللي بيجيب كل اللعبات
المهندسين
قواعد القوانين عشان لو حصل اي مشكله
من الرياضه او نقدر نعمل العقوبات معينه
وان اي دوله
يعني يصير في هذا النقاش وكذا بس ما نحن
شايفين من المتحكمه الان يعني شفنا في كاس
العالم شفنا في البطولات دي يعني
ممكن ممكن
صديقي
الروسيه على اوكرانيا طب يعني هذه بلده في
نهايه اليوم ومو ضروري وهو ياخذ موقف
مناسب لك يعني
تحديدا الاخرى ان يكون في فصل في مساله
الرياضه في السياسه ان يكون فيه حل مهم
جدا بحيث يضمن للرجلين حتى هم الاعلاميه
وشروطه حتى ما فيش قدام الجمهور طيب نحنا
بنشكرك على هذه المداخله وهذه التوضيحات
كان معنا المحلل الرياضي حسن دراس شكرا لك
يا حسن
جواد العلي فنان سعودي كان لسنوات نشط جدا
وصاحب اغاني ضاربه وحفلات وغيرها واليوم
سيره جواد العلي تويتر
النصيحه لكم انه للجميع ما انصح نفسي
دائما يعني ان نحاول نتبع ما يخوننا
التعبير عرفت شلون يعني انتبه يعني مو
معقوله فنان طالع يبغى او مذيع او
ممثل تيجي تقول له يا قدمي
يعني عيب انت سالت نفسك
سلام عليكم يا مرحبا يا اخي ما تبغى
التابعه لا تتابع مثلا يعني ابو نوره طالع
في الحفله تيجي تقعد تقول يا الله خلاص
خلوه يعتزل عيب يعني انا مرات تضايق يعني
لما اقرا كده يا ربي كيف هذا رضا انه يقول
هالكلمه او هل المفردات هذه لبوره مثلا
بدل ما يقول الله مثلا او فهمته يعني ما
ابغى احنا بس نعطي مثال انا اتكلم عن
الجميع
مثل ما سمعنا جواد العلي في بث على التيك
توك قدم نصيحه للناس اللي بتقابلوا غيره
من النجوم وبتقول لهم كلام مؤذي من وجهه
نظره وحتى للي بيكتبوا هذا الكلام المقطع
انتشر طبعا بشكل كبير ومن بعد ما نفتح
نقاش واسعوا تعليقات كثير ناس ايدوا كلامه
واكد عليك كمان وقالوا يعني فعلا عيب هذا
اللي بينقال لكن في ناس ثانيه كمان قالت
وين الغلط في اللي قال هو كان يغني زمان
وما فيش يزعل لانه الناس تقول يقعد ولسه
عايش شو شايفين الموضوع عادي
استجاب وزير العدل العراقي خالد جواني
لمنشطات مساجين صوره ونشروا فيديو لهم من
داخل السجن في بغداد
حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل يا وليد
حسبي
[موسيقى]
الله ونعم الوكيل
فيك
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله
بيتكلموا عن تعامل اداره السجن معاهم
وقالوا انه يتم اجبارهم على طاعته
المخدرات وانه بينبالهم موبايلات بمليون
ونصف دينار عراقي يعني 1025 همم والفيديو
عمل ضجه كبيره وعلى طبعا
تداوله بشكل واسع من الناس ويبدو انه وصل
لوزير العدل خالد جواني قرر اعفاء مدير
السجن التاجي ومسؤول شؤون الداخليه
وعلى فكره هذه اول مره بيطلع فيها كلام عن
انتهاك لحقوق السجناء في هذا السجن بالذات
من سنوات في كلام متقارير واخر المناشدات
كان في ديسمبر وان قال وقتها انه في سحب
اعترافات تحت التعذيب وقبور الرشاوه كمان
من يومين بدي اعمل المنتدى الاقتصادي
العالمي في دابوس بسويسرا الاجتماع
السنويه للناخذ السياسيه والاقتصاديه في
العالم واللي بيناقش وطبعا القضايا
العالميه ان كان من الحرب الى تغيير
المناخ وتاثير التكنولوجيا على الامن الى
النمو الاقتصادي العالمي وهكذا طبعا مثل
ما قلت لكم هو اجتماع مو بس القاده
السياسيين كمان بيكون من ضمن المدعوين
رجال الاعمال معروفين حول العالم فالمنتدى
السنه في 52 رئيس دوله وحكومه و600 رئيس
تنفيذي ورجل اعمال من حول العالم المنتدى
رسوم العضويه في اكثر من 140,000 دولار في
السنه واللي بده يحضر او ببقى يحضر هذا
المنتزه تحديدا الامور والجهل له دعوه
بيدفع الاف الدولارات لكن اهم رجل في
العالم او رجل اعمال في العالم مو شايفين
احنا هناك احنا طبعا سلم على رجل الاعمال
للماسك الى الماسك كان اعلن في ديسمبر انه
تم الدعوه الى المنتدى ولكن هو رفض الدعوه
وكان غرد ورد على تغريده في نفس الشهر
كمان وقال انه هو ما بيروح على المنتدى
مول لانه متورطين في مخططات شيطانيه لكن
لانه يبدوا له ممل لكن ومها افتتاح
المنتدى ادارته فتحت النار على ماسك وحولت
الموضوع لحرب وجبها وقالت له احنا اللي
اصلا ما عزمناك المتحدث باسم المنتدى قال
انه اخر دعوه الماسك لم تكن هذا العام
وليست مؤخرا قال انه اخر مره في عام 2015
وانه اسمه السنه اصلا ما كان بين المدعوين
ومن وقت ما بدات اعمال المنتدى وقال
الماسك جالس بيرد على فيديوهات متداوله
وتغييدات حوله وبيسخر من المنتدى وخصوصا
من بعد هذا التصريح فغرد جدا على فيديو من
افتتاح ذا فويس
لانه لازم نعمل برنامج مسابقات فكره ونقول
للناس جمل ويحاولوا انه يحذروا فينا نقلد
في دابوس ولا في شامفور طبعا اللي ما
يعرفها تشارفور هو موقع على الانترنت
مشهور بالترويج لنظريات المؤامره اللي
مالها اي اساس او حقيقه
من يومين بدي اعمل المنتدى الاقتصادي
العالمي في ذا فويس سويسرا الاجتماع
السياسيين كمان بيكون من ضمن المدعوين
رجال الاعمال معروفين حول العالم فالمنتدى
السنه في 52 رئيس دوله وحكومه و600 رئيس
تنفيذي ورجل اعمال من العالم المنتدى
الرسوم العضويه في اكثر من 140,000 دولار
في السنه واللي بده يحضر او يبغى يحضر هذا
المنتزه تحديدا الامور والجهل دعوه بيدفع
الاف الدولارات لكن اهم رجل في العالم او
رجل اعمال في العالم مو شايفين احنا هناك
احنا طبعا بنتكلم على رجل الاعمال
في ديسمبر انه تم الدعوه الى المنتدى ولكن
هو رفض الدعوه وكان غرد ورد على تغريده في
نفس الشهر كمان وقال انه هو ما بيروح على
المنتدى مول لانه متورطين في مخططات
شيطانيه لكن لانه يبدو له ممل
افتتاح المنتدى اداره وفتحت النار على
ماسك وحولت الموضوع لحرب وجبها وقالت له
احنا اللي اصلا ما عزمناك المتحدث باسم
المنتدى ذلك اخر دعوه الماسك لم تكن هذا
العام وليست مؤخرا قال انه اخر مره في عام
2015 وانه اسمه السنه اصلا ما كان بين
المدعوين
ومن وقت ما بدات اعمال المنتدى والى
الماسك جالس بيرد على فيديوهات متداوله
وتغييدات حوله وبيسخر من المنتدى وخصوصا
من بعد هذا التصريح فغرد ردا على فيديو من
افتتاح دافس ورد عليه هذا مصب وقال انه
لازم نعمل برنامج مسابقات فكره ونقول
للناس جمل ويحاولوا انه يحذروا فعلا
اللي ما يعرفها تشارفور هو موقع على
الانترنت مشهور بالترويج لنظريات المؤامره
اللي ما لها اي اساس او حقيقي
انتهت مسابقه ملكه جمال الكون من يومين
بتتويج المسابقه الامريكيه باللقب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
طبعا مسابقه ملكه جمال الكون بتعتبر من
اهم مسابقات الجمال في العالم والساعه كم
بتنفس على اللقب 84 فتاه من مختلف انحاء
العالم وكان اللقب من نصيب الامريكي
المتسابقه اللي شفتها في الفيديو وبتتنافس
على اللقط مع نظيرتها البنزوليه الى توجد
بلقب الوصيفه الاولى ولكن اللي كان غير
متوقع انه هذه المنافسه الجماليه تتحول
لمنافسه سياسيه ويدخل فيها رئيس دوله كمال
ونروقه
[تصفيق]
خلال الاجتماع
مشاهدين احنا وصلنا لختام حلقه اليوم انا
عدو القاكم غدا ان شاء الله في اجمل ايام
الاسبوع الخميس الونيس
[موسيقى]